I don't think anybody who says death to
America and death to Israel can be
trusted Republican candidates have
denounced the Iran nuclear deal saying
it's a threat to the United States and
Israel we're at a conservative summit in
Iowa taps likely voters their thoughts
on it all about the Iran nuclear deal
are you supportive of it
you think Iran wants to bomb the United
States absolutely do you think that
Israel's the u.s. is greatest ally yes a
port I absolutely think Israel is
America's greatest ally
they are only ally in the Middle East
that is not looking to destroy us I'm a
bible-believing Christian and I believe
those who blesses are all be blessed
those who do not will not exercise in
the fiber we need to support
so that's important to you as a
Christian even though it's a Jewish
state
they will see the light and they will
the Jews in Israel will become
Christians at the end if we back out of
supporting Israel I as strong Christian
and Libra god I think that his support
of us will also go away do you think at
all about the Palestinian Christians who
also live in the Holy Land who are
affected by Israel's policies in a
negative way you know I don't know how
they're affected I don't know a lot
about I don't know enough about that
case the Palestinians are very I'm
looking for a good word they're opposed
to Israel and I understand that you can
only coexist so long even though they
commemorated the 67th anniversary of the
neckla or catastrophe Palestinians sure
have a lot to celebrate this week Israel
and the United States have a special
relationship